[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
eleventh episode of dirty chess tricks
against Sicilian in this episode I'm
going to show you a wonderful tricky
line against specific Sicilian Najdorf
edition from the white perspective the
opening arises after the following model
E for C Phi Knight to f3 d6 d4 C
captures d4 Knight captures d4 Knight to
f6 attacking e4 Knight to c3 defending
and now the characteristic nostrils move
a6 so controlling the beef I square the
line I am going to recommend in this
video starting with the move Bishop to
c4 known as sozin variation and one of
the favorite choice of Bobby Fischer
here the obvious choice from the black
is to play a 6 blunting the diagonal of
the bishop and black is all set to play
the movie 5 with the tempo so
accordingly white plays the move Bishop
to b3 and now B fire is the most popular
choice by the black here okay what is
going to castle on the King side and now
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows black has plenty of the code
option now amongst them Bishop to e7 is
the main line however black has
frequently tried other options in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
move Knight B to d7 which is popularized
by Gary Kasparov and Black has a very
cunning idea he wants to play Knight to
c4 and then taking the bishop pair and
then slowly open up the game ok white
will continue here with rook two even
and night to see if I happens on the
ball which at first sight looks so cool
because you are achieving your target
and why doesn't have any threat in this
position well where I sold this position
in online database I found out that
there are more than 70 games played from
this position including some master
games
and I feel very pity about the white
player who lose from this position
because s it turned out that night to
see fire is a big-time disaster for the
black here white has tried many options
as I have highlighted by the arrows but
there is one move in this position which
completes the give white opening
advantage before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out what is
that move which instantly put white in a
driver seat okay let's see if you have
find this move boom push up to differ in
black is completely busted
Black has mainly for good options over
here and let's see each by turn how
white can destroy them the first move I
want to consider is rook move let's say
rook to b8
well after that white ask is very easy
you can see it right yep
it's Knight to c6 foking to big guys
Quinn to c7 and now simple Knight
captures beat if Queen captures then the
simplest is Bishop check Bishop to d7
Bishop takes Knight takes and after the
whole sequence it turns out that black
has absolutely no compensation for this
exchange sacrifice and instead of Queen
captures b8 if black continue here with
he captures defy then the task is very
easy because after it captures D Phi
which is a check and Bishop to e7 and
Knight to c6 we have pretty much same
scenario where white is a clear exchange
upper the second move I want to consider
here is Bishop to b7 which in fact
played one time in my blood scheme but I
think here once again white get the win
engage after the following continuation
that is be full attacking the knight if
the knight moves then the bishop drop so
my opponent captured my bishop I
captured his bishop and now by force
black has to move this night and it
doesn't matter wherever this night goes
let's say in the game my opponent
continued here with Knight C to d7
but after pawn captures pawn captures
and the Moon Knight captures ecigs the
track position is already collapsing and
even he's a pawn down let me show you
quickly how my opponent position fallen
apart my opponent continued here with
Queen to b6 I played a knight to defy
attacking the Queen he continued it
Knight captures defy I recapture with my
queen attacking the rook in the corner
so he played rook 2
8 but after a night captures g7 a double
discover checks so black King has to
move and after came to the hater night
to e6 track King to hate Queen to h5
check King to e7 Bishop to g5 check
Knight to f6 Knight to see if I again
discover check King to d8 and the
finally the deciding blow Queen to f7
and black resign at this position and he
cannot deal the double threat and maybe
he is fed up with his King tons
you
the third move I want to consider is
what happens if you opponent accept this
piece sacrifice with he captures defy
well after that white response is very
obvious he is going to capture with the
I porn
giving black a discover check and that
means by force black has to move the
King why
what happens if Bishop e7 well the
simplest reply is Knight to c6 and black
is going to lose a piece
so that's not good news for the black so
here by force if black doesn't want to
lose a piece then he has to move the
King and King to d7 is the only reply
well after there you can already see for
a peace sacrifice we already misplaced
black King white initiative doesn't stop
here in many lines not only white get
the piece back but because black King is
stuck in the center he get a furious
attack and a winning combination here
White has a forcing sequence starting
with the move before hitting the knight
Knight goes to the a4 and after Knight
captures pawn captures and the Moon
Knight to c6 attacking the Queen one of
the master game continued from here
onwards Queen to b6 Bishop to e3 Queen
to b7 but after the Moosey fall it is
very clear that for one piece not only
white is able to put this knight on a
wonderful square but black king is stuck
in the center and he has some horrible
pawns to deal with it it is very
instructive to see how quickly a master
has fallen apart black continue here
with Bishop to e7 so he desperately want
to get his pieces in the game but after
White's
hammering blows such as Bishop to c5
sacrificing a piece but hitting on e7 so
black responds his force he has to
defend the e7 Bishop with rook to e8
and how smoothly white initiative
continue with Queen captures a fall so
there is a discovered attack on the king
and the funny part is King cannot go
anywhere otherwise black is going to
lose a piece in the game black find
nothing better than capturing this
Bishop but after Knight to a5 I discover
check to the King King to d8 Knight
captures Queen Bishop captures night and
after all this transaction it turns out
that
okay black has three minor pieces for
the Queen but because this King is stuck
in the center this position is quite
favorable to the white side last but not
least what happens if you open and
denied the speech sacrifice and take
with his own night night captors defy
well this is probably the easiest one
because now I can simply capture this
nine so no longer white is a piece down
and you can already see there are so
many attacking potential on e6 so black
responses force he has to continue with
the movie Phi and after there is our
familiar territory yup it's Knight to c6
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and now
the another forcing move before hitting
the knight Knight to d7 and again white
initiative will continue on the Queen
side with the moon in phone so there is
a threat of a captures B Phi so black is
forced to capture this pawn and after
that instead of routinely capturing back
White has this wonderful move in the
picture b5 well black has two options
whether to capture this pawn or continue
with his King side pistol of mange if he
continued with moves such as Bishop to
d7 then the problem in this lines are
white can continue with Bishop to b3 and
still black cannot castle on the Kings
side because the e7 bishop hang and if
he try to be sneaky with the move Bishop
to d8 protecting the bishop and now
ready to castle but there is not enough
time as after Knight to e4 this King is
not going anywhere
and the second option a kept his beef ax
is neither good for the black as well
because after night captures be fire
attacking the Queen Queen to b6 and c4
you can see those wonderful nights
sitting right into the guts of the black
cam and black cannot do anything about
it now to illustrate the danger in the
black cam I like to show you one of the
high level game where black continued
wait Bishop to e6 trying to get rid of
one of the night white continue with
Bishop to e3 attacking the Queen Queen
to b7 and now very simple win captures a
for pinning down that poor bishop okay
black lace Bishop to e7 what else but
now comes another thread rook e to be
one trying to get a discover check and
nabbing the Queen
so black side stop it with Queen to c8
so still black is surviving but after
White's next reply black simply place
the resigned button before I show it to
you I want you to pause this video and
find out that wonderful move which
forced the resignation
are you ready have you considered this
wonderful move Knight to e7
creating a roadblock for the bishop and
unfortunately black cannot deal with
both the threat in the game after Queen
to c7 and Queen captures in six white
emerge with a peace advantage and black
still cannot able to castle on the Kings
side well I hope you enjoy and long this
amazing tricky line against Najdorf
variation thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care